Good evening.
Good evening to Good evening. Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir. Good evening.
Good evening, sir. Good
Evening, sir.
All of you are back on your place,
whoever had visited Triple 80 harbor?
Not yet, sir. I'm on my vacation with my kids. Oh yeah.
Okay. Okay. So you should talk with others.
How has your experience not in this class?
Maybe sometimes later. Okay. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. We'll wait for, uh, Taha. I joined.
Good evening, sir.
Good evening, Al. Good evening.
Yes.
So, um, Dr. Sunil, how do we proceed?
I will start with CNN today or,
Uh, yes, sir. We can start
with the CNN first staff.
Then when I'll take over, I will just take them
through the, some programming.
Okay. Yes, sir. That is what I have
Hope, uh, screen is visible.
Yes, sir.
Let me also, let me know when should I start under,
We can start, sir, around 40 people up there.
Okay. Yes sir.
Recording. And,
Okay. So,
um, good evening all, uh, um,
See after, uh, know, we,
uh, transitioned from
multi-layer perceptron to, uh,
training the deep feed forward neural network.
Uh, the next important, uh, breakthrough that came in
deep learning was, um,
the conation, the use of con networks,
especially in, um, image processing
and computer vision task.
Uh, they, they were hosting, uh, uh, no
international challenges across the globe
for object detection from the images, uh, no, uh,
images primarily.
Um, this is there as an interest challenge.
Before this even d learning came in, came into picture.
People were trying classical machine learning approaches.
But, uh, especially you may be knowing, you know,
there is a, a public repository of ImageNet, a large number
of images, public collected images are crowdsource there
and put it there for advancing the research
and image processing, especially
for our object detection task.
There, I think, um,
Hinton group itself, um, uh, they,
uh, explored the usefulness
of conversion neur networks in the object detection task.
And again, no, they demonstrated a very significant increase
in the performance.
Okay. So as a result of that, that, again,
that is another breakthrough, which gave a push
and impetus to, uh, take this attention
of the deep learning model means, uh,
interest in the deep learning model to the next level.
Okay. Um, so that, that, that is where one
of the most versatile deep learning models are conversion
neural networks, and, uh, all
of you should invest the time in mastering
the usefulness of conversion neural networks.
That is what we are going to discuss in this body,
that deep feed for network, which we studied so far, just
to get a feel for
how the transition happened from multilayer perceptron
shallow network to the deep network
and show some improved performance and the acoustic model.
All those things I showed, uh, dril earlier
that improvement in the performance. Uh,
Sir, last time you discussed a little, uh,
that, uh, deep learning, uh, how this a NN uh,
and deep learning, we transitioned why we transitioned
and all, ah, that a caustic model,
I think you have not explained here.
Yeah. That part is
No, let, let me then show that so
that it makes a transition.
Yes. Maybe others can comment
because it's difficult for me to keep track.
Yeah. Yes. Let me see whether
Advanced concept, this one, yeah,
I'm just opening that and, uh,
Did they explain about this?
Any of you can comment please about breakthrough
and replanning then Grady layer explaining.
Did they explain? No, sir. No, sir. No, no, sir. No sir.
It's not explained. Okay.
So let me, um, so c we explained about, uh,
vanishing radiant problem, exporting radiant problem.
That's what Sarah explained in detail.
Now, will I will, uh, just this continuity, I will give,
um, uh, the,
because even though it is a history now in the sense, um,
um, uh, this model itself, uh,
is not very great now
because we are seeing that after 20 years.
But this is the result
that gave breakthrough in the deep learning,
and this is published in as a paper in 2006 by Hinton
and the group, a fast learning algorithm
for deep belief network neural competition.
So that is the, uh, first, uh, breakthrough paper,
which was, which came.
So essentially, uh, how that breakthrough was, I will, I,
I'll try to explain this deep neural network,
because of the large number of layers,
and in each layer we have large number of neurons.
So accordingly, we can treat this as having a many levels
of nonlinearities.
So accordingly, they can potentially represent highly
nonlinear, highly varying functions.
They can complex machine learning functions, they can model
or complex pattern recognition problems they can model.
Uh, but
however, till 2006, uh,
even though conceptually when the proposal that is
what they were hypothesizing,
their performance was not found to be better,
even in some cases, it is worse than, uh,
the shalon neural networks.
Okay? With one or two done layers.
Actually, in case of speech recognition, we have a
one publisher result.
They have showed, um, that, um,
instead of having your three layers, hidden layers
of multi-layer perceptron, I can have one hidden layer
with large number of neurons.
That itself is sufficient to handle any non-linear tasks.
That is what they proposed, okay?
Which is almost like a support vector,
mission working principle that whatever we are telling,
no linearly supportable.
And, uh, the other one is which are not
linearly supportable.
Again, there are two subcategories, convex and non convex.
Uh, so the, the hypothesis by them was, uh,
that is where no to deal with, uh, non,
which are not linearly separable, but convex nature.
You add one more hidden layer, again,
which are not non convex.
Then again, add one more hidden layer like that.
We did multi layer receptor.
That connection is the approach for speech recognition,
her bollard and, um, uh,
another person have written the monograph is
available public domain.
This demonstrated that instead of this three layer,
I will have a single layer
with very large number of neurons.
Then you are mapping the data from lower dimension
to very high dimension.
In high dimension,
any nonlinear problem in the lower dimension gets converted
into a linear classification.
There, you can, uh, you can do, do the classification
and bring back the classification results.
That is a way later supporter vector machines
for essentially working principle was that.
So people concluded like that you don't have
to include more number of layers
because it doesn't give any inform in the performance.
So only one layer is sufficient like that people are argued.
So in that way, even though this theory was there,
multiple done layers, all those things, uh,
they were not found to be better
and even often worse than shallow neural networks.
Um, then maybe as we explained earlier,
now the gradient based optimization,
starting from random mineralization will get stuck in poor
solution for such deep networks.
But what, uh, always know, I told this
Hinton group, EOS group, one more person, either Lannan
or something, their group will continue
to work along these lines.
They were of the h are a hypothesis that no,
there should be some way
of training these deep learning models.
And Professor Hinton group, uh, know, came up
with a method for training.
Um, it is, see, it is not, uh, that they call it
as a greedy layer wise, unsupervised learning algorithm
as a principle to solve the problem
of training deep networks
that gave a much needed breakthrough.
But what I wanted to hypothesize is it is not
that greedy layer wise training algorithm was not there in
the literature at that point of time.
It was there, but it was,
it is being used for some other purpose.
If you take this deep belief networks,
there are feedback neural networks to train that feedback.
Neural networks, feedback neural networks.
They use this greedy, uh, layer wise unsupervised, uh, uh,
learning algorithm, but then never visualize
that algorithm can be used
for a deep feed forward neural network
because it's meant for feedback.
But these people felt, oh, can I, instead of,
since I'm not able to train this deeper network,
I will take layer wise, when I take layer wise training,
I treat this as a, a two layer feedback neural network
and apply that greedy layer wise unsupervised
learning for training the network.
That's all the idea and it worked.
And that is that, uh, created, uh,
you know, a required breakthrough in the, um,
in the deep learning literature.
What I wanted to say is no.
For example, I, while, um,
Before, um, explaining, uh,
the propagation learning algorithm as a motivation,
we mentioned that nearly for a decade
or so, the whole neural networks field was halted
because we were not knowing how
to train a feed forward network.
That multi-layer perception problem was there.
Then the much needed breakthrough came in the form
of a BAP provocation learning algorithm.
But this is not, like not, no, they came up
with a breaking algorithm
for training the deep feed for networks.
This algorithm was already there,
used in the feedback neur network context
that they brought it and, uh, showed, uh, uh, that no,
you can try
and, uh, a deep feed for network using that principle.
So that is why I am trying
to emphasize too much here is, uh,
no timing is important in, in early turn of the century,
people who are having the ability to collect large amount
of data in any machine learning task easily
without much effort,
and there are computing powers like GPU came,
that is another coordination.
The third one is the third came
where I can use greedy layer wise spine.
All these came in handy
to demonstrate this 2006 breakthrough.
So the principal was
in the unsupervised greedy layer was training the principal
was, um,
since I'm not able to try
and suppose, let us consider a case of, um, say,
um, a seven layer
deep feed forward neural network
In a seven layer deep feed forward network.
Uh, I have input layer
and an output layer leaving that five layers are there.
When I take this fight
and layer, I will call from the input side
as the first done layer from the input side as H one
followed group that has H two
and so on the H five is the done layer
before the output layer, H one to H five one there.
Okay. Now, uh,
this, um, um,
since if I stack all of them together
and simply trying the propagation algorithm,
that vanishing gradient problem
or exploding gradient problem, we told.
Now what they did was in the greedy layer by training.
Now I'll take the input layer
and the first layer, H one, I will pull that out out
of the field for network one.
Okay, I will only take that one pair of layers.
One is the input and the H one, take them separately
and treat that as a feedback,
neural network feedback neural network.
There's no output from the H one layer.
Uh, for the training purpose, I apply the input
to the input layer,
and it goes into the, uh, the
hidden layer neuron output and the lead neuro.
Since I cannot tap the output of the hidden layer one,
I will fed feed back that, uh, uh,
output back into the input layer.
So naturally, say I'm applying some input, and
after going to the a DH layer one
and coming back, there is a reconstructed
value for that input.
So there is a actual input I've applied
and there is a reconstructed input that is coming
and find the error between them
and use that error for adjusting the weights in
that pay network until you reach a point where,
uh, the error becomes minimum.
So the name greedy came into picture,
because when I'm training a given hidden layer,
I don't have the target output.
So if I don't have the target output,
the approach I take for learning the weights information is
I only know the input, how best I can
reproduce the input, how best I can reproduce the input.
So that is what is called greedy.
I, I am greedy towards reconstructing the input
as much as possible because I only know the input.
Okay? Um, each layer is pre trying to model its input,
ignoring the effect of higher layers.
This is this part, you don't have to worry
because see, always there is a doubt looming in our mind
that, oh,
this hidden layer H one is not an independent layer.
It'll be forming a part of a feed forward network
with the H one to H five.
What will be the effect of those layers that we don't bother
at this point of time while training?
I only know the input for this layer, this pair of layer,
and my goal is the learning greedy layer wise learning is
my, uh, learned to wait information should be such
that I should be exactly,
or if not exactly closely reconstruct the input
that is applied to the input layer of that done layer.
That's what each layer is pre-train to model.
Its input ignoring the effect of ILAs.
If you, how does the effect of the ILAs is taken?
Once we train each individual, H one, H two, H three,
H four, H five separately, I stack all of them together
to form a seven layer network.
After that, I apply
for fine tuning web propagation learning
algorithm once or twice.
Then that effect of higher layers,
to some extent will capture that is the way people are now.
So, um, now, um, when
in an unsupervised way,
because I don't have the target, uh, output,
that's why I call it as an unsupervised way
and using learning at each layer in order
to preserve information from the input.
So what is done is maybe I will, I look at, uh,
yeah, I, let me show you this, this figure may help you.
Don't worry about the nomenclature given here.
So this is the input vector.
So I applied through the input layer,
and this is the first layer, okay?
And there is a weight metrics W one,
which is the weight metrics between the input layer
and the layer.
Um, so while training this,
I use a greedy layer wise training.
This feedback, I treat this as a,
this page as a feedback network.
That's where arrows are shown on either side.
Signal flows to here and comes back. When it comes back.
So for example, I take the first input, it is connected
to all the neurons in this layer.
Then accordingly, no, the,
this input is also represented weighted combination
of all these nodes present in the hidden layer.
So then I get the reconstructed input, you know,
the actual input and take the error between them,
and that error is usually for adjusting these weights.
Okay? Now,
and this process continues
until the reconstructed input vector, uh, the error
between the reconstructed input vector
and the actual input vector is minimal.
Then I'll stop and say this, W one
has learned actual distribution of
the input data points
because it is the best representation
for the input data points.
That is what this See now, when you are training,
this is not part of the, the final network.
For example, if I take no, finally, when I, when I say this,
whatever this layer, GRBM is there in a deep belief network,
it forms like this or
otherwise, if I take it a feed for network,
this layer GR BM layer comes
and sits one layer one, then this RBM comes as done.
Layer two, this RBM comes as done.
Layer three like that, this, they'll, they will sit
as done layers, okay?
But while training here, greedy layer wise,
I don't care about this higher layers I pulled out
and trying separate that is greedy layer
and unsupervised greedy layer.
Once I trained this for the best of the abilities,
and these were used as the initial weights
for while training the BAP propagation algorithm.
Finally, you can see this W one transposer user.
These are the weights learned
through the grid layer wise training.
Okay? Then how do I train the second layer?
How do I train this second layer to get W2?
What I do is I apply the input to this,
this fa and layer,
and I generate the output from that firsted done layer.
I don't know what is the target output,
but the, the best representation is there.
I get the output, and those are used as input
for training the seconded done layer.
Now this, the firsted trained firsted done layer access,
the input layer, and the inputs for that is the input pass
through its hidden layer access.
The input for this, uh, uh, hidden layer one
and hidden layer two.
This pay is taken.
I try and really layer wise, this process is continued.
Then pass this output through this,
and that is taken as input trying this W three,
then stack all of them together
to form a deep neural network
and then use the bap propagation algorithm to try,
and this is what the date, greedy layer wise training.
Unsupervised trial. So any, any doubt here to any of you?
Uh, sorry, sir. I have a, a small doubt. Yeah, please.
Normally, uh, Sarah model is trained to give,
uh, some output.
Mm mm Uh, so if only input is restructured, uh,
is it the output we can call?
No, that is not the, uh, no output means.
See, one way is suppose if I take a a,
actually the neurons are there,
they will also give output here,
but the thing is, okay, for training, I do not know
what is the target output I should get here.
If I have the target output, I can take the output
and find the error and use it for adjustment.
But in this case, exactly, I don't have the target output.
That's why what I do is I go by an indirect way. Okay?
So I push the balls this side
and reflects back like that.
Now, I've passed the signal through the weighted values,
it gets distributed to the neurons in this layer,
and again, comes back.
When it comes back, I collect all the inputs
and represent how much of this
particular dimension is
reconstructible from the weight metrics.
Okay? Okay. That is how it is done.
So, so then this, this restructured input, uh,
which is coming out of, uh, out from the first layer,
will act as input to the next layer.
Uh, uh, no, no.
See, while training, this gets optimized in such a way that
okay, this W one will become an optimal state, okay?
When the restructured input, the error
between the restructured input
and the actual input is minimal,
Okay? Okay. Okay.
Then what we say,
this W one has essentially captured the inherent
characteristics of the input data points, okay?
Okay. It's a faithful representation
for the input data points. Input
Data, okay? Okay.
Then I pause all this input through this.
For every input vector,
there is an output coming from the hidden layer
Layer, okay? Okay.
And those are the corresponding map input
vectors for the next H one
Next layer, next H one. Okay? Okay,
Sir, this is what we, Okay, sir.
Thank you, sir. Thank you,
Uh, sir, compared with the deep neural network,
because here, uh, it is separate like, uh, uh, the output
of first GRBM is taken as input separately for then
where W2 is applied while applying back propagation.
Uh, can we use the chain rule in similar way like we were
using in, uh, deep neural network,
or we can't use like that?
Oh, this is a wonderful question C.
Once all this, see earlier in a conventional deep feed
for network, this W one, W2, W three, W four,
they're all trained, uh, by random mineralization,
some random initialization.
You put it and, uh, go and train. Right?
Now, what happens at that point?
I have the target output here,
and I, I also know the input vector when you train.
This W four gets suggested properly
because I have a good access to the gradient
where the gradient value decrease the ca
decrease the ca further decrease the ca.
That is where W one is least affected,
at least adjusted because the gradient has
vanished by this time.
Okay? So now
this BAP propagation algorithm remains unchangeable, uh,
um, compared to what we were studying earlier.
The BA preparation remains same only as it earlier, okay?
And accordingly, the vanishing gradient
problem is also there.
Only thing is, even though this W one is relatively less
adjusted, since it is already captured the input data
information, it is able
to pass the signal flow from input to the output.
Did I answer the question?
So, uh, still we need the,
the change rule will be applied while calculating the
Yes, yes. Okay. The
change tool
as followed in the B application in the final, this,
this is fine tuning.
When we do, we don't do that exhaustive training,
like suppose earlier from the scratch, if you're training,
if it in 30 posts now it may be four
or five pokes, I fine tune it.
Okay? Okay. Not, yeah.
Okay, sir. Clear. Thank you. Okay,
So in the previous question, I think by chain rule,
you meant gradient descent
because chain rule is a calculus, uh, fundamental,
No, no.
Whatever gradient descent algorithm we were using,
say algorithm, we use it here also Uhhuh,
I see While doing the, the algorithm remains same.
See, once I fine tune, I copy this weights
as the initial weights for the feed for our network
and just trying as a deep feed
for our network using web application learning,
Right, sir? Got
it, sir? Yeah.
So it trains faster without those problems.
No, trains faster means, see, earlier there was a
big block hole here.
Yeah. Now I have already intelligently, uh, trained
represent the data.
Yeah, sir. That is how it helps,
Sir. And this, uh,
W2 is also trained when we are training
W2 with the direct.
So do we have this inputs directly connected
to W2 and then train it?
Oh, this is a wonderful point.
So what we do, ruby, this, once I try this W one,
I pause all this input data through W one
and collect the output at the output of GRBM.
Ah, And those are used as input to this.
Uh, see, this GRBM is nothing but this, this layer. Okay?
Oh, in the copy.
Now this input applied here is the output
of JRBM that is applied here.
Otherwise, there is no deploy difference
between W2 and W one.
Exactly. Yes,
Correct. No,
mm-hmm. So what we do is once we train,
we pause all this data through this W one
and collect the modified out outputs from the CH one.
They act as input to this pair of H one, H two,
Right, sir? So, sorry,
sir. So, um,
and when we say this GRBM is finally trained,
then we have done already, uh, the training
with one layer. Ah,
So while train, while training this GRBM, ah, I only,
I take this pair of layer, this green is an input layer, uh,
and GRBM is the hidden layer.
H one uhhuh. I am training independently greedy layer
wise, right?
Greedy means I don't know the output,
but I know only input, uh,
my weight adjustment objective function is such that when I
reconstruct the input using this W one metrics,
that reconstructed input should be ideally equal
to the input or with least error,
Right?
Then I say this, W one best represents the
input data input.
Yes, sir. Got it.
And that is the approach taken for training greedy layer,
Right, sir? So
these things have a meaning. These G-R-B-M-R-B-M,
Ah, see, uh, they call
restricted boardman machine, okay?
Uhhuh restricted boardman machine.
This g if I'm not run, I don't know, some gian
or something they call, but the seated boardman machine is
a, it is a, a feedback neural network.
Ah-huh. It's a feedback network,
but we don't have to go to that level.
Now, that's where I did not expand that.
Okay, sir. Thank you, sir. Yeah,
Okay.
The, the, the W four equal to zero there means, ah,
that's the actual discrimination you're trying to
Do there. Ah,
wonderful, wonderful.
See for this W four,
I don't require Grady representation here,
because gradients are so high in the output layer.
No, it can easily learn that independently
by the B propagation learning algorithm,
and it provides that discrimination
because I need that
for a discrimination classification purpose.
Okay? See these W one, W2, W three R
essentially to capture the dis distribution of the input,
what is presented to that layer, whereas this W four is
for classification purpose
Makes sense.
This W four is not meant for capturing the distribution
of this output rather than it is meant
for capturing the discrimination among the different class
In What about bio storms, sir?
Bio storms are all part of that.
See, they're, they're there as a part of that.
See that I'm not taking out,
they're all inherently when I'm trying,
the weight factor means that biotherm w
not is also trying together.
Yes. Got, Okay.
So, um, see, what they did was no,
they demonstrated, there's an
handwritten digital recognition task, uh,
is a well-known data set.
People collected, uh, uh, if I'm not wrong,
about 10,000, uh, images
for each digit handwritten digit images.
They collected zero to nine maybe thousand for each case.
10,000 images were there by NIST organization.
They call it the standard written digital condition task.
And this, uh, essentially
how when an handwritten digit image is there,
how well you can, uh, classify
that into those 10 digits.
That's what is handwritten digit recognition task.
And this was a well known, uh, uh, till today, people use it
as a good data set collected by, uh,
available, publicly available.
They even with the, uh,
classical machine learning method, for example,
I take support vector machine.
If I take support vector machine is a
classical machine learning.
It is not a deep learning model
that gives 1.4% as the error.
If I, uh, use the, they have a standard classification of,
uh, train validation and test dataset.
That standard test dataset, if I apply it gives me an error
of 1.4%.
That means to say 98.6% is the
accuracy of detection
of this handwritten digital recognition di digital
recognition images, okay?
The performance is so high.
So when, when you, when your classification performance is
98, 99 like that, uh,
you can't achieve know 0.5% improvement in a next classify
anything, any 0.1% change in the performance is treated
as statistically significant
because it's, the performance is so high already.
If it is 50%, okay, you get 5% improvement,
that can be a statistically significant,
but here at 98.5%
even 0.1% change in the performance is
statistically significant.
Okay? So, uh, so
accordingly, what they did know, they proposed a,
a generative model, uh, of, uh, uh,
deep feed for network input E 7 84, um,
it is 28 plus 28.
Uh, how much is that? Uh, 7 84.
Can somebody tell me 32, 32 or 28? Yes sir. 28.
28, ah, 28 plus 28 images for there,
and that I make it as one dimension.
It becomes 7 84 that all the images are 28 plus 28 images
converted into 28 plus 28, and converted into one dimension.
That becomes 7 84.
And the classification is a 10 class classification.
That is, the output layer is 10 dimensions,
then hidden layer one that had 500 neurons,
neurons hidden.
Layer two has 500 neurons
and hidden layer three as, um, 2000 neurons.
Now let us call between seven eighty four and 500.
I have W 1 500, 500, I have W2,
502,000.
I have W three and 2010, I have W four.
This using 7 84
and 500 I greedy layer was training to get W one,
500 and 500.
I get W2 502,000. I get W three.
This W four I don't learn.
I put it in the deep neural network configuration,
initially randomly initialize it.
Then I learned through the B propagation learning algorithm
only with that, they showed 1.25% error
from 1.4 to 1.2 5.15% decrease in error.
Of course, you may say no, what is the big deal?
As I told 0.1%, it is more than 0.1%.
And that is how they were able to show to the world that
when I do this greedy layer wise training, I'm indeed able
to show a significantly improved performance.
Okay? And as a comparison,
they did a bab BAP propagation algorithm,
simple B propagation algorithm, 7 84, import 10
as the output and two done layers, 400, 300 like
that they did, and some cross andro y dk,
they got 1.51 as there are even inferior.
This is even inferior compared
to support vector machine 1.5%.
Again, they did only single it layer. They got 1.53, okay?
And they reduced, uh, no, uh, they put secondary layer,
but you know, about 15 or something, uh, squared
and online updates 2.9.
So this is the journey people were struggling from 1990s.
Okay? You can see now the Shalon neural network
and, uh, this one, they're inferior compared
to support vector mission.
Okay? So as a result of that, uh, people had left the
interest on the, uh, neural networks,
but this is the result which now created the interest
for the community that we can indeed, uh,
trying, um, the, uh,
by greedy layer wise concept.
I can try the deep learning ones,
but one, one point I want to say is, um,
it is not that.
Um,
So it is not that, uh, this data is very big here.
If you see adminis data set,
the data set size is very small.
Um, but still they're able
to demonstrate greedy layer wise training effectiveness.
That is what is the importance of this, okay?
Um, once they did it
and publish it in this paper in 2006, this neuro
neural computation paper, this
group, they, they,
they did an independent work and they published this paper.
Greedy layer was training of deep network proceedings in,
uh, NIPS 2006.
You people should download
and read that paper, see just for the beauty
of the work they have done.
Now, see, these are the two, uh,
cornerstone papers on which this deep learning field,
hello, please mute.
Uh, so this greedy layer, they, apart from
greedy layer wise unsupervised training, what, uh,
uh, intern group demonstrated they independently implemented
that and showed that yes, it works.
Second thing they did, they did with a supervisor training,
really layer was supervisor training.
Okay? Uh, we'll see how they do that supervisor training,
because I was telling no, there is no output available
for it, and layer how they have done, we will see.
Okay? Um, so what they did was,
uh, their contribution is reinforcing
that greedy unsupervised learning works.
And, uh, second thing is they also came up
with supervisor versions of greedy layer wise training.
Both they demonstrated, okay?
And also they showed the effectiveness of, uh,
greedy layer wise training.
Okay? That is what they did.
So how did they demonstrate the supervisor version
train each new hidden layer as the hidden layer of
one hidden layer supervisor network?
Okay? Um,
but of course, now the question comes to your mind
that now you, you are telling that, uh,
there is no output for the target output for the down layer.
How do they try?
There is one neural feedforward neural architecture
called auto encoder.
In the auto encoder, uh, input is applied to the,
uh, input layer, and the same input is applied
to the output layer.
Okay? Let me say that target output is same as input.
That means to say, I'm trying to compare the given
vector with itself.
Like, no, I'm looking at the mirror to look at myself. Okay?
I do that, and as a result of that, I try to learn the,
the generative process involved in
producing those feature vector, okay?
And that is what is called auto encode.
And now for supervisor training, what that it is,
suppose I take that input layer H one, okay?
So let me go to this here, input layer,
the GBMH one is there.
Then what I do is I put an output layer, which is same
as the input layer, okay?
Now what I do is I apply the input.
The target output is also same as the input.
Let me say I'm quoing the input director with itself.
That's why it's called auto encoder, a network
with auto encoder configuration.
Now, what will happen is here,
the hidden layer will act as an encoder.
Either it can be a layer dimension or a bigger dimension.
It encodes the input
to some dimension vector in the hidden layer output,
whatever the number of neurons are there, and
accordingly, it is captured in W one,
and I have an output layer here put,
which is same as the input layer.
Then the goal here is
in the forward part from input to written layer,
the W one should capture the actual distribution
of the input data points.
Once it captures then from the output,
whatever it is generated encoded output, I should be able
to reconstruct back the input.
Essentially, the weight here should be w
inverse of this weight.
So that, no, there is a transformation happening.
W one into W one inverse
will give you back the same input data.
So that is the working principle of an auto end code.
Now, I have only one layer chosen to be trained.
Then I put it in the auto end quarter configuration,
and W one encodes the input to this hidden layer
and the W one transpose
or W one inverse, whatever you want to call,
we'll reconstruct from the encoded input
to the actual input again.
And if I'm successful in doing that, then
I throw away the output layer,
throw away the W one inverse output only.
I will take W one, and that will be the pre-trained,
uh, value.
Okay? Uh, see, one way is
I don't need to go through that, uh,
restricted boardman machine approach for training,
which we are doing in the unsupervised training here.
I can try using, uh, um, Uh,
even if I, you know, uh, I try using
a simple feedforward neural network,
but the only thing is that output function,
the cost function will be different.
The cost function is for a simple means squared error.
I can use it as a cost function and train it,
and that is how I train the, um, try, uh,
train each hidden layer as the hidden layer
of a one hidden layer supervisor network.
One co one way of doing is auto encoder. Okay?
There may be other ways of doing that also, we can,
but one best example is, uh, using auto encoder.
So then throw away the output layer
and use the trained hidden layer
as a pre-training initialization of the next, okay,
and repeat this process taking as input the output
of the previously trained layer,
and the, I pass the input through the hidden layer output,
and those are connect, the used as the input
that process remains, uh, same as unsupervised layer.
Finally, fine tuning
by adding a logic regression layer on top of the network
and training the whole network by stochastic gradient,
centra entropy with target class,
some approach they have done.
So now, uh, uh, just to,
what is the significance of this?
Is this paper what they have shown, the HO profile,
The experiment two, uh, e no, they,
they conducted two experiments, experiment tools was
proposed done by whatever they have done in interns paper,
published it earlier, the experiment three,
they designed it.
They, they did a new experiment.
They wanted to demonstrate that if I reduce the number
of neurons in a run layer towards the output layer,
towards the output layer, uh, how the perform
performance, it affects the performance, um,
uh, for shallow or without pre-training deep cases.
That is the additional experiment they have done.
Anyway, let me, uh, show this,
this deep belief network unsupervised pre-training.
This is what Hinton's group demonstrated.
Experiment two was same as Hinton's group experiment.
They independently demonstrated that for the trained data,
a hundred percent correct validation data, 1.2% error
and tested also 1.4,
they showed a 0.5% further reduction, and there are 1.25.
They brought it down to 1.2.
And this first row up to this point was
the, um, the, uh, repeating the experiment of
group and reassuring to the community that yes,
if I do greedy, unsupervised pre-training of the network,
then it is indeed possible to train a deep neural network.
Okay? And the experiment threes, they try
to play with the neurons, number of neurons
in the hidden layers towards the output layer.
For example, uh, this 2000 is there,
this is the hidden layer towards the output layer.
If I start playing with this 2000, instead of 2000,
I make 200 or 100 or what?
That is what they did, they try to vary the number
of neurons from 2000.
They decreased the number of neurons, then the,
the errors started increasing.
That means to say that large dimension is required
as something they wanted to show.
Of course, the, the purpose is, so now
the auto associated pre-training deep network auto
associate, this is supervisor training, okay?
These two are supervisor pre-training.
They have done auto associator pre-training.
They got this 1.4%, 1.4%,
which is, uh, no,
uh, poorer.
It is equal into the toughest support vector machine.
Uh, it is not, uh, um,
good like unsupervised training at that point of time,
but, uh, they showed that no, it, it, it is not in inferior,
like, uh, uh, a deep network
without pre-training a shalon network without pre-training.
This is the performance. 2.1%, 2.4%.
Let us consider only test column.
See, without deep network, without pre-training, 2.4%
shalon network, no pre-training.
1.9% compared to
that is associate performances 1.4% that Mr.
Say ability to show the, uh,
uh, trying the network in a supervised manner,
also possible, but their performance is not
like unsupervised.
Sorry. Okay. Even the other methods
of supervisor pre-training also, they, uh, showed,
and there's 2.5, 2.2%, which is, uh, equivalent.
That shallow neural network only this auto pre-training came
like a support vector mission, okay?
So, um, what they wanted
to show in this is these are not very statistically
significant results, like unsupervised that we say,
reinforcing that UN supervisor pre-training is still a much
preferred method, but it is also possible to train
by auto associate pre-training network.
The other part they, they showed was of course,
0.1% is statistically significant in this case.
Um, what they wanted to show is this experiment too.
If you consider even training, uh, even Shalon net network
use good performance on training data.
If you see the training data now 0.0%,
zero zero 4%, okay?
Which is we get a, uh, feeling
that, oh, it's good.
Channel network is also, uh, doing a good job.
That means to say this good performance is attributed
to over fitting for the actual data training data.
Then if I go for experiment three, if you reduce the number
of nodes in the done layers towards the output layer, okay?
Uh, instead of the 2000, I make it less numbers.
You know, you, you can start,
start seeing the deterioration in the
performance SHA network.
There are, which deep networks are zero, zero,
this becomes 3.6%.
Okay? That means to say, uh, this,
these 4.1%, 5% indicates that, uh,
in this earlier case, which was almost showing equal,
and to some of the deep configuration doesn't mean anything
because it was just memorizing or fitting.
Whereas if I try to play with those
neurons in the hidden layer just previous
to the output layer, the brittleness
of the shallow neur network comes into picture.
So this is what they wanted to show.
That is another novelty they have showed as a part
of this network, these two works know, uh, really
caught the attention of the community that, oh,
this intern group
and group, uh, should recently showed that it is possible
to train deep net.
It's big network.
So any, any questions up to this point,
the supervisor training results are not that attractive,
like whatever you are getting unsupervised,
but they showed a direction that by supervisor way also,
we can try the, Any, any questions
or clarifications here.
So, so can you go back, uh,
I think it was discussed sometime back,
but I just wanted to confirm that, um, that image, right,
GRBM, uh, so if you, if you have input,
I, I just,
So we give input and then there's a W one
and GB BM is there,
and uh, we have some output form coming, right?
And then, uh, in the next citation, we have to really, uh,
change the weight based on the difference
between input and output, right?
But again, the input and output are in different formats.
There's no output here,
There is some form it.
How do you really change the input of how?
See, um, for example,
I take a one dimension, suppose assume that there are 10
neurons in this JRBM, right?
The first dimension is divided into this 10 neurons input.
It is a fully connected network, okay? Yeah.
So let us call W one one, W one 12, W one, three, et cetera,
W one 10 and the weighted combination of that,
what I applied to this 10 neurons mm-hmm.
Will be the fraction in which this input dimension I'm
dividing ID okay?
Okay. Yeah. And while, while coming in the opposite way,
I take the same thing and represent them.
So, so that, that, that is, uh,
some latent space representation, right, sir?
Ah, that later, ah, that this, for example, whatever the
outputs that, what is this output coming
out of these neurons?
I call it as some latent space representation,
reducer dimension representation of the input
or something we can say.
So, so whatever the, each neuron output I get say, uh,
let me call this as H one one, H one two,
H one 10, the output of the 10 neurons.
Then this input dimension, since it has contributed
to H one one to H one 10, yeah, I,
the reconstructed input is a weighted combination
of this H 1 1 2 H one 10. Okay? And
So in the next citation of the training, uh,
let's say input is some handwritten
digits, uh, number, right?
And then the output is some latent space representation.
How, how do we compare
to change the way it's right in
the next citation of the training?
Like we keep moving on citations
to change the way it's right. So,
Hmm.
Uh, can you, can you please repeat?
So if, if I have, uh, the input is some, uh,
handwritten digit nine, for example,
and then the output is a latent space representation of
of H 10.
Hmm. Um, so I need to change the weight again.
Uh, again, rates are, uh, just for every input we have
to do, and then we need
to really compare the output to the input every time.
Is it not the case, the latent space
to the input should be compared,
or we shouldn't do that at all?
No, the latent space compared
to the input means the latent space value
as a weighted combination will reconstruct this particular
dimension, okay?
For this faster dimension from the input is represented
as a weighted combination of this latent space.
H 1 1 2, H one 10, right? Contemplate with the same weights,
Okay? And that
reconstructed, let me call it
as this is first dimension is X one, I get X one dash,
Okay, X one dash is compared
with X one in terms of means squared error.
Okay? Okay. That is what I do
Means quite Okay, sir.
Thanks.
Exact reconstruction I'm looking into.
Okay, sir, thanks. Yeah, yeah.
Okay. So, uh, so just to summarize,
the first breakthrough came by unsupervised Grady,
layer wise training, second breakthrough.
They reinforced that Grady layer wise training works.
That is for the handwritten dig, dig recognition task.
Now, the people from speech recognition community,
they took notice of this
and they felt, can we
see whether it works in the speech recognition?
And here there are four different groups across big players,
if I'm not wrong, Microsoft, Google, I, BM,
and Hinton group.
They independently worked on the speech recognition task
and they documented this in deep neur network
for acoustic modeling speech recognition,
I triple E signal process magazine number 22.
It comes there, you can read it is an independent, that is
for handwritten dig recognition task image processing task.
This is for speech recognition task.
In the speech recognition, one of the basic, uh,
task we do is what is called pH recognition task.
Uh, no, and the classical method
that was there till that point was what we call it
as continuous density hidden Marco model
stochastic model approach.
It's a non neural network model, machine learning,
classical machine learning model.
It is giving an error rate of 27.3.
In 27.3, you can see.
Now there the error was 1.2,
1.4% like that.
But here in case of speech,
because of the large variability available,
the prevailing error rate was 27.3.
Ideally it should be as low as possible, okay?
The prevailing was 27.3.
Then when they used this, um,
monophone deep belief network, deep neur network,
six layers, okay?
Um, one is randomly initialized, deep neur networks.
Then deep belief networks, uh, DN Ns,
they got 22.4% from 27.3,
22 point maybe, I'm just guessing no, maybe 1%,
maybe a statistically significant from 27.3.
They showed it 22.4%
and that was a big breakthrough in the result.
Okay? Big breakthrough in the result.
And uh, then now it became, you know,
suddenly caught the attention of the community
and they further see while doing 22.4%,
they were using handcrafted features in case
of speech we call male frequency cap coercions.
They told, they also played with that.
You don't need to do that type of sophistication,
feature extract, handcrafting,
you can even get the rudimentary features.
That's what they did.
What do we call filter bank energies that got 20.7%.
You can see now, initially people got the shock
of their life because, you know, for 30,
nearly 30 years people are struggling around 27.3 to 26, uh,
like that, suddenly they got this
nearly 7% improvement in the performance, mainly
because of this greedy layer wise training
that they demonstrate.
Okay? And then how does, uh, again, they demonstrated
for speech recognition also word that is phony error rate.
Next one is the word error rate
and some different para, different dataset hubs data,
switchboard data set is there rich transcription data.
Then for example, word error rate was 27.4.
For this one, they brought in some 19%,
19.7 0.1, which is again,
a significant improvement in the performance.
Same thing they demonstrated with the 27.4,
18.5 that came.
So what it ultimately with these studies, speech recognition
and handwritten studies, it was demonstrated beyond doubt
that it is indeed possible to try
deep feed forward neural networks by using
greedy layer wise try greedy layer wise strike.
Okay? Um, of course later now
after 10, if you see know, um,
either you take the AMNE data set
or this timid data set that we were using speech recognition
or this hub bridge transcription data set, all those things,
the data size was not that great compared to
what we are using now.
Okay? Uh, uh, see now we are talking about 1 million hour
of speech data for training this large
speech, large language models.
At that time, they used 3, 309 hours of speech data.
At that point, it was big,
but, uh, what is most important was
it is indeed possible to try
and deep network using, um, Pretty layer which time.
And that was the, you know, breakthrough, uh, in the, uh,
transition from it cemented the transition
from Shalon Deep network.
Okay. Um, any doubts here,
maybe, uh, Sunni, I will stop here.
Let us do the CNN next class. Okay,
Sir, that is Fine.
Can you hear me? Yes.
Yeah, yeah, very clear, very clear.
Is, is this, uh,
taking still approach still relevant today
in given modern techniques?
So like batch analysis?
Uh, can you repeat?
Sorry, repeat?
No, what I'm asking is, uh, we have lot
of modern techniques, uh, like relu
and, uh, batch processing or the batch normalization
and all this is approach still relevant today, sir?
No, it is not relevant now. It is not relevant now. Okay.
Uh, I, I did not comment that.
We will see when we go there, we'll talk, uh,
with the good optimizers available now, okay,
you don't require really layer wise training,
but if you have less amount of data, for example,
no, you have a few hours of data
and you want to train the deep learning model to be
of useful on an A wise or something there.
This really layer wise training is still useful,
Right? But you
have 1 million hours
of data then you don't require, you can directly try.
Got it. Got it.
Okay. Thank you. Uh, yes, sir.
So my request is no, whether you understand
or not, my humble request to all of you is at least, uh,
read this, uh, download those papers, 2006, uh, ance paper
and, uh, uh, NIPS 2006 paper
and just read it just for the, the purpose
of appreciating their effort.
If they would not have done, uh, what the
claim we are doing on the whole
world would not have been there.
That's why they got that noble award.
If you see that paper, it's not,
there is no mathematical equation there.
Okay?
Uh, yes sir. I actually, so
what you brought out about this both unsupervised
and supervised greedy algorithms,
and I can slightly correlate
as we thought the CNN in the initial first semester,
how this weights are carrying power later on,
and how we are able to go for a specific task, like you say,
the supervised, uh, learning where we take each
and every layer and then we train it,
and for the specific task, we tune those weights.
So accordingly we can slightly correlate how it is evolved.
So in that way, I think these two algorithms are, uh,
just really eye opener kind of things on this kind of, yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
Thanks. Thank you, sir.
Okay. Uh,
someone was telling anything or what?
We still have time, so we will, so you,
uh, don't leave the meeting.
We're continuing. Maybe I'll just take over
for next 10 minutes, 10 to 15 minutes, okay.
Okay. So, uh, just to, uh, summarize, uh,
what we were trying to, uh, presented
to you that this, this neural network deep learning, I mean,
there was a certain periods in which certain, uh, uh,
breakthrough was given.
See the initial that there was initial time when we started
with the single neuron, we said it
as a perceptron network, right?
And then we extended it to the multilayer perceptron network
and we learned how
to train those multilayer perceptron network
with the back propagation algorithm.
That much, I guess all of you are clear, but
after that, the problem which
occurred was the vanishing gradient problem, okay?
That, okay, we have the multi-layer perception network,
but when we start training, there is a problem
of vanishing gradient problem.
And that is happening because we have number
of hidden layers in between
and the weights, which I'm trying to back propagate, okay?
It is not able to update the weights in the initial layer
due to the vanishing gradient problem.
Fine. So that was the problem where we stuck,
and this, these two, uh, papers,
which I had just explained this was you can say that one
of the solution to that particular problem that, okay,
we cannot train very deep network due
to the vanishing gradient problem, then what is the way out?
Okay? And we struggled a lot, okay?
The, the whole communi community has struggled a lot,
and that's how this novelty in terms
of the layer wise training, they said that, okay,
do not train this deep network altogether
because that's where there is a problem, okay?
Because your gradients are being vanished,
weights are not being updated,
hence the laws are not being decreased.
What you can do is you pull adjacent layer train that,
then pull next adjacent layer, train that,
then pull next layer, train that, okay?
So in that way, what will happen, that weight, uh,
weight will be well, uh, initialized between the two layer,
because now it, it knows that how it, how it was trained
and, uh, what will happen, the vanishing gradient problem,
which was the, uh, problem that we can address.
And that is what we did. That is what we did
with this unsupervised
and supervised greedy layer wise training.
And this was carried on till 2012. Okay?
Till 2012, almost you can say that. Fine.
Then when
after this 2010, 2012, uh, uh, when
we, again, we shifted again, we shifted to our initial mode
where we were doing the back propagation.
We are training the whole network at once means we are
feeding the data, whatever number
of hidden layers are there, we calculate the final output,
we calculate the loss, and we do the back propagation.
This was the initial, uh, initial, uh, like you can say
that the method which we we're following,
and in between this greedy layer wise training was the
solution for the, you can say that this Spanish gradient.
But around this 2012, again, we shifted back again,
we shifted back to our initial mode,
and we started training the whole network again.
Okay? So what, why, why we did, why, why, why we were able
to do that one because of multiple regions that one
of the regions was like activation function that relu,
the relu is activation function, which was able
to mitigate the vanishing gradient problem
up to a certain extent.
So we started using the relu activation function in the
hidden layer, because if it is a sigmoid, then
what it will do, it'll always compress the value
between zero and one,
and it's a very relatively smaller number, gets multiplied
with another gradient, another smaller number,
and it'll give further a smaller value.
That was the main problem, really doesn't do that one fine,
but that was one sol.
Uh, so, uh, uh, Relu was one solution, other solution,
which there was, uh, talking about better
initialization of those weights.
So how do we initialize the weight?
That is what it matters many times, right?
So better initialization weights came into the picture.
And another, another, uh, reason what a tool that we now,
when we are in 2012
and onwards, we are having huge amount of data.
Huge. So
before that, suppose 2006,
all these experiments were approved around 10,000 data, 20,
20,000 data.
Now going for forward in 2012
or so, we are having lax millions of data.
So that was another problem that, okay, uh, this, this, uh,
for larger data set, okay,
how do we train this layer wise, layer wise?
Then the, another, another, uh, uh, point of shifting back
was the G-P-U-G-P-U came into the picture,
which was not earlier there in 2006, okay?
So people, not people were not utilizing the GPU power.
So that was also in place.
So we started exploring that part, then drop out
to address this over fitting problem, batch normalization,
you know, all these, uh, all these, uh, uh, you can say
that, uh, uh, things together led us to again,
switch back to our initial mode
where we were training the deep neural network
end-to-end, end-to-end.
Instead of training layer wise, we started training again,
it from end-to-end.
Okay? So in between there was a six to seven years time
where this greedy layer wise, you can say that, uh, uh,
training was proposed and it was a game changer,
which has given all to together different perspective that
how to come up, come out of this ING rating problem.
But later on today, we are not, uh, like, um, u utilizing
that greed wise, uh, uh, layer wise training.
But, but, uh, as I said, if you have a small amount
of data, you can still use it.
Not valid, because of the reasons, which I have told you,
we are now, when we are in 2025,
we are still doing the end-to-end training
with the back propagation, what we have learned so far.
But this was the phase,
and you must be knowing that, okay,
what are the different phase we have gone through
and we have reached to this 2025, and what is the status?
So this whole journey we were presenting to you. Okay.
And these two were the breakthrough in between,
and you must be knowing it at least.
And, uh, uh, maybe, uh, the, uh, uh,
like conceptual wide little bit exploring the paper will
really help you to, uh, bridge that.
Otherwise, you may be missing this link.
You may never know that. Okay. Why it is required. Okay.
Why, why it came into the picture at all. Okay.
So that was the whole purpose that, uh, why, why we have,
uh, uh, spend some more time to explain you
that particular part.
Alright? So, okay.
So, uh, what I'll do now is that, uh, I will
present my screen, uh,
uh, one second.
So I'll just present my screen.
Uh, what we can just, okay.
So next, from the what I thought that I will, uh, start
that I will give you a little introduction on the PYS neural
network module, which we have not started
PyTorch in general, we have seen
and we have already implemented our neural networks with
that also implemented the back propagation and all,
but neural network module, we have not yet, uh,
started in detail.
So I will see that in next 10 minutes how much I can do.
So I able to start with this today
and then we'll continue in the next class. Yeah. Before,
Before we start, I have a quick question.
Yeah. Um, so we, we started with this, uh,
singular multi-layer perceptron
with the mostly labeled data.
Mm-hmm. Uh,
but now we have, uh, this, uh, exploding amount of data,
which mostly we will not be able to label them.
Correct? Right. So, uh, why that, uh, particular,
you know, greedy, why greedy layer wise training, which help
with the unsupervised, uh, unsupervised training,
uh, supervised training, which depended on these, uh, um,
what we call those, um,
distribution data distributions rather
than labeling of data.
Why those strategies are discarded?
Because I, I feel they're more relevant.
We are doing statistical based, uh,
loss functions rather than, um, label wise loss.
So it is not discarded,
the concept itself is not discussed.
If you see these, all these
large language models which are utilizing
the whole internet data,
they are still not relying on the labels.
Right. Okay. So that, that's what,
that's why I told you the concept, which was given then
was now being used in the different, different forms.
So we are now not depending on the labels itself,
because we can't have, we can't have the labels
for all those millions trillions of the data.
Right? But at the same time,
what has happened is going into complete,
unsupervised way, what they have proposed.
Now, we have some other kind of paradigms also,
which is in place like self supervised,
like semi-supervised.
So I mean, you can still go with unsupervised, greedy,
layer wise training and all.
I mean, they, they're still valid in the sense,
but then, uh, with this huge amount of data, if you go
with a self supervised for lms, that will be, you can say
that more, be better
and, uh, you can end to end, you can represent, uh, the,
the distribution in a better way.
You can train it, you can converge a little faster way
because you have hundreds of such layers with this, say
that 700 billion parameters, uh, with these huge networks
and all having some self supervised setting is working
better than the unsupervised.
But having said that, unsupervised is still being used in
certain cases, maybe in the large language model it's not
being used, but in some other cases it is still valid
and people are using the auto
incurred concepts and all. Yeah,
Okay. Okay.
Yes Sir. Excuse me, sir. I have a doubt, sir.
I mean, here, uh, what do we do with the biases, sir?
The biases, I could not see that in the neur and work
Biases you could not see,
but you have to feel the biases as you're breathing.
So breathing, you can't, uh, always think
that I'm breathing, but you,
you are always breathing, right?
Yeah. So without breathing,
you can't sustain it is biases or something like that.
Although it, we are not showing explicitly
with the neuron biases are there or not.
But by default, biases are the part of the neuron,
which is there everywhere.
Okay. Okay. Yeah.
So whenever we do this weight sum, we also add the bias.
So only thing what we have done is we have considered
bias as another input.
So we are not explicitly mentioning, uh, it,
but then bias, uh, the way we have learned
with the single perception, it, it,
it is the same way it is being carried
for any kind of neur network.
Yeah.
Got it. Thanks. Yeah.
Okay. Alright.
Alright. So I was just, uh, showing this particular slide.
So, uh, what we are going to do from the perspective,
because ly we have to implement everything,
what we are going to learn in this particular course.
Okay? So next is the CNN, what we are going to start with.
And before starting the CN, uh,
because things are going to be a little complicated
and we will not write everything from the scratch,
each equations and all, hence we'll utilize this source
NN module from the PIs
and how, how it'll help us, that it'll help us to first
create the, you can say the blueprint of the model,
what we want to create,
and then how to create the forward propagation, how
to calculate the loss, okay?
How to, uh, do the back pro, back preparation, how
to update the weight and all these things.
Whatever is required for any neural network, for training,
for ev almost every module, uh, you have the storage
n support, you have torch.
So I'll show you that one slowly, maybe today it,
I will not be able to show,
but all these things it is able to handle,
it can update the weight, it can add activation function.
So it has support from all kind of activation function.
And you did not write the, uh, encode from the scratch
for the relu separate function for say
that 10 edge separate function.
You can simply call that function from the storage module.
Similarly, the loss function, uh, there are a lot
of support from the loss of,
for the loss function in the PyTorch, like, uh,
binary cross entro laws like, uh, squier loss, similarly,
automatic gradient competition we have, right?
Or different kind of optimizers we have,
and we have something called as containers like, uh,
sequential container.
So I'll show you that in the next class.
What is the sequential container
and how does it help us to, uh,
like attach the different layers in the neural network,
like input layer, haal layer, next digital layer,
and we have whatever concept we have learned that okay,
output of one hidden layer will act as an output
for the input for the next general layer.
So the sequential container are able to do that.
Otherwise, we have to, uh, uh, uh, uh,
define individually each layers in the code,
but that we don't do usually
otherwise our code would be too long
and it, it, there is a chance of doing the mistakes as well.
So once we define our blueprint with the sequential, uh,
container, we can, in one line you will see
that you are doing the whole forward
propagation just in one line.
So that is what I'm going to show next,
maybe in the next class and going forward,
all these concept will use for all the, uh,
like complicated network like convolutional neural network
or recurrent neural network or transformers.
We are going to utilize this neural network module.
So what I have planned is that I will, uh,
I'll share anyway, this slide with you, uh, like,
although I've not explained where
what I have done is I have taken a simple network, okay?
For example, there is a single neuron where five,
five inputs are connected, one bias,
and then it is given the output by hat.
And there is a, uh, there is a, uh, you can see this, uh,
there is a, a whole notebook,
which I have prepared just for your understanding.
And with this notebook, what I'm trying to do is I'm trying
to, uh, introduce this neural network module.
So here, what you will see, uh,
that there are certain object oriented
concepts are coming into the picture.
That's why in the last class I have, uh, explained
that you must be knowing some object oriented concepts in
Python, which is quite easy, not very difficult.
Also, you may have to read it, uh, for once
or twice, do a little bit of practice.
You'll understand that. So here what I'm doing is
after importing the torch,
I'm also importing thoughts dot NN neural network as an n.
There's just a, uh, you can say the variable
with which I'm going to use the storage n module
here in this particular code, what is happening is I'm dev,
I'm creating my class
because I have to create one model which model, this model
where I have a single neuron
and five inputs are being connected with this neuron.
This is the model which I want to create.
So I'm creating a class of that model,
and this model will inherit the, uh,
inherit the parent class that is called anin module,
which is available here in this thought nl.
So there is a concept of inheritance.
There is a concept of inheritance.
So NN dot module have lot of attributes
and methods available.
It's another class in the torch.
So this, my class is inheriting all the
properties of n ndot module.
So this signature is about the inheritance in, in, uh, in,
in, in, uh, Python right now.
You will see that there is this particular method, uh,
every time whenever you will build a model class,
you will be having one line like that
where you are writing in it.
But this particular, this is a function.
This is a function where, which we, we are defining
and this function in known as this function is known
as constructor.
So there is a concept of constructor in
object oriented programming.
Okay? So I'm giving you pointers
because I'm not going to explain you this whole code today.
Next class I'll explain,
but meanwhile you can ex just, just go
through these pointers like what is inheritance concept
and how can we do the inheritance, uh,
in the objective preventing programming in Python?
Then what are the concept of constructor?
So constructor is a function by default.
It's a function, but it's a special function.
So whenever you will create an object of a particular class,
the constructor will automatically execute.
In general, what happened whenever you define a function
like forward is a function.
If you want to execute this forward, you need
to call this forward function.
Unless you are not calling the function, it cannot execute.
But constructor is a special function
which will get automatically executed
whenever you will make your object of a particular class,
if of this particular class.
Okay? And how do we represent the constructor
by the signature, it says underscore, underscore in it,
then underscore, underscore.
Now this is the special, uh, signature, uh, which we use
for this, this constructor.
So in it is representing that it a constructor. Okay?
There is one more keyword, which you will see here.
It's super, okay.
Now this is also very important
and we, you should be exploring it by yourself.
So super is a key word which we use to connect
with the parent class.
So here you can see that the parent class is NN dot module.
Now in the n dot module, the python, uh, pythons, uh, uh,
programmer who, who has already written this particular
parent class, we are inheriting this class here.
So in that particular class, we,
we already have some attributes, some methods defined
with this super key word.
What we are doing is we are trying to access the attributes
and methods, which is already defined
inside this particular parent class.
So we are calling again the constructor.
This again the, uh, signature of constructor in it,
but of the parent class.
So super keyword is used to call the constructor of the,
or connected with the parent class.
And in the parent class, I'm calling it constructor, okay?
But these three lines are very important.
So three in these three lines, there are three concept
of the object object oriented programming.
You have to learn. First one is the concept of inheritance.
Second one is the concept of constructor.
Third one is how to connect with the parent class,
the concept of this super keyword.
So, okay, super.
So now there is last thing, which now I'm telling you,
dressed we'll see in the next class.
There is a self word.
So you can see that self keyword self
here, self here, everywhere.
You will see self, self, self, self.
So you have to also understand what is the importance
or significance of the self.
So I'll tell you now later, you can explore
whenever you create a class like this, okay?
And when you create an object of this particular class,
okay, so the self represent self at the name says this,
it's yourself, okay?
Self is the object of this particular class.
Suppose I'm creating an object
of this particular class as object one.
So object one and self is same.
Object one and self is,
and that I'll, I'll show you in the next class why
I am saying it to the self.
And you see that self is going as an argument
for this constructor self is going here.
Also self is going here.
Also self dot something like you call like
object dot something, right?
So self is acting is being acted here as an object.
Self is acted here as a parameter Here.
Also self is being acted as an object.
So self is an object
and it is representing for all those objects
what you will create for, for this particular class.
Okay? So what I would recommend, I'll stop now, uh,
I'll share this slide for you here in the slide.
You have three notebooks.
This is the first notebook I've shown you.
Then I have little more complicated network
with one hidden neural network.
One more demo, one more, uh,
where I'm showing the sequential container, okay?
And fourth notebook is about the neur network pipeline,
where I have done all these things, loading data, train,
test, place model, building, forward pass loss calculation,
backward pass and optimization.
I'm going to upload this, uh, uh, whole slide with you.
You try to do the, the practice for all these notebooks,
understand the concept of object programming,
what I have explained in the next class.
We'll start with this
and I'll see that if you have any query, I will,
I will quickly answer.
Otherwise we'll pass on this one.
You have to do the practice, all these things by yourself.
It's are simple. Everything is simple so far, so
that we can utilize these concept in the upcoming classes
when we'll build even little complex network.
Okay? So that is the, uh, that is what I, I, I just,
so anyway, Saturday you will not have class.
So now, uh, your task could be do, uh,
just execute all these things by yourself,
all these notebooks, by yourself, uh,
and just see that what is happening.
Use the, use the chat GPT uh, snippet up code to understand,
okay, what it is doing, what is that particular keyword,
what is that par parameter and all just do it by yourself.
And still, if you'll have any query,
we'll start from this slide in the next class, uh, to,
and I explain everything.
No problem. Okay? So I will stop here.
If you have an inquiry, you can ask me,
Sir. One question, sir.
Yeah, sir.
Instead of using constructor, like any module
or package would be able to solve this problem, right?
Why do we need to go with the constructor to, uh,
protect this problem? So
For, for that one, you have to understand
that's why a little bit of concept of this object
to inter programming
that we see constructor is a function, as I said.
So as you said that why can't I use any other module?
Module is nothing but another function, right?
So why can't I use, I use built-in function.
Uh, that is your question, if I rightly understand.
So yes, the
what happens basically every time when you create your
neural network, every neural network is slightly
different, okay?
Neural networks are quite flexible
and you can design your neural networks.
As for your requirement, it may be three layers.
Sometimes with four, four neurons, it may be 10 layers,
sometimes with a hundred hundred neurons,
not this constructor gives you that flexibility
to have the blueprint, what you want in your neural network.
I mean, uh, that, that is how,
and based on that, later on you will see
that you will design the forward propagation, okay?
So that if you will, uh, uh, import that module
as you're saying that, uh, instead
of constructed some other module, then what will,
and that flexibility will go away.
Okay? Now, but, uh, so if you want to have that flexibility
that you, whatever way you want
to design the neural network in that way,
you can con construct it.
Constructed is required
and that is why the constructor is important in this, uh,
uh, in this particular way.
Okay? I'll explain that in the next class.
Maybe you will understand it a bit.
Thank you, sir. Okay.
Any other queries so far from anyone?
Maybe we'll go through that.
Ah, please, I'll upload this slide.
Just do the practice, at least just run it
and see that what is happening
and use the chat g PT
to get the understanding of those codes.
Then we'll see that in the next one.
Okay? Bye. Thank you so much.
Thank you, sir. Yes sir.
Thank you, sir.